Da gestern habe ich es erst wieder auf whatsapp gelesen viele von euch haben angst vor einem atomunfall, im belgischen atomkraftwerk
djs ist wegen zahlreicher störfälle regelmäßig in den schlagzeilen und tatsächlich risikoanalysen zeigen
Im worst case würde die radioaktivität in richtung deutschland verbreitet die städteregion aachen würde bei einem reaktorunglück
unbewohnbar und auch das ruhrgebiet köln und düsseldorf wurden verstrahlt
Also was würde ein unfall, im atomkraftwerk teams bedeuten gibt es möglichkeiten sich vor der gefährlichen radioaktivität
Zu schützen und was muss noch passieren damit sich belgien von der atomkraft verabschiedet jetzt in klicks und salz entwickeln herzlich willkommen
Nicht nur die meisten expertinnen und auch politiker innenbehörden städte und gemeinden sehen das belgische atomkraftwerke als großes risiko
liegt in der nähe von lüttich und ist nur etwa 70 kilometer von aachen mit seinen knapp
250.000 einwohnern entfernt düsseldorf in köln sind etwa 130
kilometer weit weg das ist eigentlich ein
unscheinbarer kasten mit drei druckwasser reaktoren gebaut ende der 60er jahre der erste block ist seit
1975 in betrieb doch die sicherheitssysteme sind überholen immer wieder kommt es, zu grösseren
Störfällen und zwar zu größeren nachdem der reaktor für einige zeit vom netz genommen werden muss 2002 kam es zur bislang
schlimmsten störungen ein ventil stand einige zeit offen der druck viel ab und das kühlwasser verdampft das ist ziemlich schlimm eine kernschmelze
wurde durch die sicherheitssysteme
verhindert der protest gegen teams wird immer größer mittlerweile gibt es sogar klagen gegen das
kernkraft einzig und allein belgien selbst hält daran fest die
Atomaufsicht des landes hält die reaktorblöcke für sicher dabei ist der druckbehälter mit rund achtung
3200 rissen übersät wie bitte no risk no fun oder was nur das alles andere als fun
werden es ist einfach komplett bescheuert wie die menschen offenen august die leben von millionen anderer menschen in gefahr bringen das erinnert etwas an
fukushima schlimm die stadt aachen sorgt lieber vor als nach werten darüber berichtet die behörden hatten vergangenen jahr jodtabletten
verteilt die verhindern sollen dass die schilddrüse
Radioaktives jod aufnimmt eine wirklich klasse aktion die es bundesweit bisher nur in
Ausnahmefällen und nur in sehr begrenzten regionen gab und den nachbarn ist es sehr ernst zitat je nachdem wie das genaue
szenario aussieht haben wir ganz große zweifel dass wir es schaffen jodtabletten rechtzeitig zu verteilen das sagt der verantwortliche koordinator
Markus krämer damit meint er verschiedene faktoren die das horrorszenario
atomunfall
Maßgeblich beeinflussen was passiert der unfall nachts oder tagsüber wie ist das wetter gibt es starken wind und regnet es und damit dem worst case
nicht auch noch schnell und in panik
ausgabestellen für jodtabletten eingerichtet werden müssen sorgt meinen aachen lieber vor und zwar nach der empfehlung der
strahlenschutzkommission denn die empfiehlt für gebiete der außenzone für den fall der freisetzung radioaktiven jods
infolge eines schweren reaktorunfalls die verteilung von jodtabletten die kosten für die ganze aktion übernimmt übrigens das land nordrhein, westfalen
Das will schon etwas heißen eingenommen werden sollen die tabletten aber nicht vorsorglich sondern erst wenn die
katastrophenschutzbehörde dazu auffordert das alles sei eine reine
Vorsichtsmaßnahme heißt es in einer offiziellen broschüre der stadt trotzdem sagt das schon echt viel aus wenn die politik und die verwaltung
So eine maßnahme für nötig hält wir haben hier ja schon öfter über atomunfälle
berichtet doch welche fatalen konsequenzen hätte ein unfall
im atomkraftwerk teams das liegt nämlich ziemlich ungünstig expertinnen und experten haben genau das in
risikoanalysen untersucht der auftrag an das institut für sicherheits und
reaktor wissenschaften in wien kam von der städteregion aachen selbst und die ergebnisse sind
katastrophal und
Angsteinflößend zugleich in der untersuchung analysierte das forschungsteam vor allem tausende wetterdaten um zu sehen in welchem ausmaß und in welche richtung
Die gefährliche radioaktive
Strahlung gelangen würde fest steht falls die hülle von
france 2 birst könnte dies ein unfall in der größenordnung von fukushima bedeutenden das risiko ist
gegeben dazu der beteiligte kernkraftexperte wolfgang renneberg
Wie sie auf die hälfte seiner dicke ist ein reaktor druckbehälter mit rissen durchzogen das ist ein sicherheitsrisiko
dass man nicht dulden kann
explosionen und feuer würden das ganze verschlimmern und die radioaktivität massiv erhöhen
Wenn solch ein unfall passieren würde könnte es sein dass ganz aachen
Unbewohnbar wurde das forschungsteam berechnet dazu ein risiko von
18 prozent die radioaktive belastung der stadt sei dann vergleichbar mit der in der 20 kilometer sperrzone um
Fukushima so renneberg falls eine extrem ungünstige wetterlage herrscht mit
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit erreicht die radioaktive strahlung bei einem unfall aber das
25 fache der belastung die ein mensch durchschnittlich pro jahr
Aushalten muss auch bei diesem wert müsse die region evakuiert werden
So dass studien themen auch andere teile von nordrhein-westfalen wie etwa das ruhrgebiet mit seinen fünf millionen einwohnern
Könnten der studie zufolge verstrahlt werden ebenso wie düsseldorf und köln am rhein
insgesamt wohnen in dieser region 10 millionen menschen hinzu kommt die zusammenarbeit zwischen den betroffenen ländern deutschland belgien und den niederlanden
Das ist alles andere als optimal das haben niederländische
sicherheitsexperten und experten festgestellt sie waren davor dass wohl alle länder ihr eigenes ding machen würden
katastrophenpläne müssten eigentlich besser abgestimmt werden und bürger besser informiert werden
und als sei das nicht alles schon tragisch genug auch finanziell
solch eine atomkatastrophe
Gigantische schäden zwar gibt es fünf internationale abkommen die die haftung in solchen fällen übernehmen
Zitat das problem dabei ist nur dass sie zu erwarteten kosten um ein vielfaches. Höher sein werden als die in den abkommen
festgelegten haftungssummen und
deckungsvorsorge summen das sagt die wissenschaftlerin lena reuster zur erklärung ein super gau also ein riesiger atomunfall
Würde wohl kosten im dreistelligen milliardenbereich
verursachen dreistellig die
haftungsgrenzen der betreiber liegen daher
Im dreistelligen millionenbereich die obergrenze für die die akw-betreiber in den meisten eu staaten
Haften müssen liegt unter einer milliarde in belgien und in erlangen sind es immerhin 1,2 milliarden euro es gibt rechnung nach denen die geschädigten
Bei, einem unfall in trance wohl nur ein prozent ihres schadens ersetzt bekommen würden anspruch gegenüber dem deutschen staat besteht gar
Nicht klar ist jedenfalls nicht nur die behörden sondern vor allem die aachener bürger sind mehr als verunsichert immer wieder mal gibt es
Katastrophenübung gegen die drohende atomare verseuchung viele halten die verteilung der jodtabletten als noch nicht
ausreichend auch schutzkleidung gegen den radioaktiven staub sei wichtig diana fordern dass die orange
Abgeschaltet wird denn nur das sei ein effektiver schutz für die bevölkerung doch bisher ohne erfolg ihr problem wird nicht kleiner denn der atomausstieg
belgiens ist ja extrem unwahrscheinlich eigentlich hatte man sich schon 2011 darauf verständig bis
2015 den atomausstieg zu schaffen doch das land ist abhängig von der
atomenergie wie kaum ein anderes land in der eu ohne sie droht stromknappheit die
risikoanalyse aus wien jedenfalls zeigt noch einmal deutlich dass große
sicherheitsrisiko das von t orange ausgeht der weitere betrieb sei nun mit solch einem
Seriösen nachweis dass auch die region betroffen seid noch weniger hinnehmbar so helmut etschenberg chef der aachener
städteregion anfang 2016 hatte die stadt region aachen geklagt und einen sogenannten nichtigkeit
Am tag vor dem staatsrat eingereicht es richtete sich gegen das erneute hochfahren
des reaktorblocks 2 sowohl die länder nordrhein-westfalen und rheinland-pfalz und auch über 100 kommunen aus deutschland den niederlanden und luxemburg
waren beigetreten seit rund einem jahr wird jetzt vor dem gericht erster instanz in brüssel geklagt wird die stilllegung
des kernkraftwerkes 2 gefordert die begründung die persönliche betroffenheit
Im falle eines schweren atom- und falles wenn ihr als erste neue studios
Und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video eben vorab und das garantiert könnten
direkt in der redaktion vom krieg so mitmachen und mir themen vorschlagen oder andere vorschläge machen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau der glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
bereiten sich auf atomunfall vor ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran